[Music]
you are you're you're you're an unusual
fellow
I'll give you I've known you for a
number of years and I say that as a
compliment you're very original and I'm
very curious was fred armisen like as a
kid I you know I think I was I tried
maybe a little I tried hard to be like
be kind of funny and creative but I
think it went the wrong way like when I
was in eighth grade I wrote this paper
about you know the assignments for
English class what would you do if is
your last day on earth to live and I
wrote this paper that all the other
students were kind of like I'd go visit
my family and I'd go you know walk
around the park and and I I wrote this
thing that I said I would just destroy
every store on my street how it smashing
windows but I think as an adolescent I
was just being like I don't know I just
I was just it was like kind of trying to
be funny and I said I would like to
light all these places on fire and I got
sent to the school psychologist I spent
the day yes I said it was so scary but I
was trying to be funny but yeah I just
didn't work out okay this is something
you brought this was a that you were
asked to write a poem yes this we
actually this is an actual poem that you
wrote we have a a photograph you have
the real poem and what does it say here
blood Dracula sucks blood and so do I
many insects suck blood even a fly by
Freddy Armisen
[Applause]
[Music]
that would yes I also get you sent yeah
yeah yeah what was more than it's more
than ego or maybe how about that yeah I
am Freddie Hardison